Josh Holley is a top-tier Republican
recruit trying to unseat one of the ten
Senate Democrats hoping to win
reelection in a state president Trump
won Missouri Claire McCaskill Trump beat
Clinton in the show-me state by a
whopping 19 points and tomorrow just one
day after the 38 year old Attorney
General Holley started campaigning and
four months before the party's primary
President Trump is flying in to raise
money for him I look forward to having a
Missouri hopefully more times the one
hopefully he'll be here frequently the
last time this seat was up 2012
McCaskill won easily because her
Republican opponent congressman Todd
akin was caught up in controversy over
comments about quote legitimate rape
this time McCaskill allies are treating
Hawley
as a legitimate threat to her third term
she's held 50 town halls in the last
year alone and so you know we're gonna
take it very seriously we're gonna be
out there working hard but Democrats
think a scandal at the Statehouse will
help them the governor Eric Greitens a
Republican was recently indicted on
felony invasion of privacy charges
stemming from an extramarital affair
this is a person that has put himself
first over party over citizens Polly
doesn't see the governor dragging him
down the situation the governor is not
good for the state and that as the
Attorney General the state that's what
concerns me most instead at stop soon
raid town and Springfield Polly hinted
that McCaskill hindering the president's
agenda is what this race will hinge on
she voted no on tax relief for working
families she voted no on justice courses
she voted no on regulatory rollback yes
so they're right there I mean she's
voted against the interests of Missouri
and with her parties and that's what
she's gonna lose so the way Holley sees
it you're either helping President Trump
or you are not and that is how he has
been shaping this race as we have
followed him around on his campaign bus
on this first day of campaigning across
Missouri in this one of the places that
Republicans are very aggressively trying
to flip a seat